what will happen in Berlin in two days
they have something called the list
cadenza which is basically a wall of
balloons white balloons there's some
8,000 of these balloons they trace about
a 15 kilometer stretch of the old line
and then sometime after sundown they
will be released into the sky and that's
really the big moment here
I hope we have some video up of it's
gonna be pretty remarkable the
Brandenburg Gate is behind you what
portion of the berlin wall still stands
Oh less than four hundred meters I mean
you know depends what you call me what
you classify the wall was it just the
part that divided East Berlin from West
Berlin or is the part that divided
Berlin itself the the back side of West
Berlin from the city the municipality of
the state of Brandenburg right very very
it's just for tourists and Brenda
Greeley with us who spent some serious
time in Germany I mean you lived there
several times and reported from there
and Hans you know how big of a cultural
force now 25 years later is what they
call a stall gia the nostalgia for the
former East if you come across it I mean
look oh and Berlin a lot of the sort of
east-west divide isn't so much an
east-west divide it's a north-south
divide and it's old Berliners who are
upset about Swabians and Bavarians who
are not only coming to Berlin with all
their money but also their work ethic
that's deemed to be just a little bit
more a little bit more industrial than
lineal to Berlin's a party City right
yeah he's been a party city well it's a
party city but I want to bring up a
photo that I remember seared to my
childhood memory and this is when the
dialog changed folks that is Peter
Fechter 'he's body he was a teenager
this is a grim photo of a grim august
1962 in this photograph changed the
debate on communism Sir Martin Sorrell
whether some w PP and Sir Martin you
went through checkpoint I went through
check for an Charlie about 1963 it's a
year after that force actually sorry no
not sixty of 65 could you feel the
tension of that absolutely absolutely we
went into
Prague we went to Prague took us 12
hours to get the prize the train journey
was meant to be six hours over double
obviously couldn't speak any Czech at
all or we didn't read it so it was
pretty its first time in my life I
couldn't read the language not with the
question understanding really but
checkpoint charlie and East Berlin was
extremely grim at that particular point
in time and it's a it's an amazing
change from where we were yes and I
think there's a you know one of the
things hard to remember is how much
confusion there was at the time in 1989
you know the 25 University that they you
know it was almost an accident that the
wall was opened you know I I had a
friend who ran through that night and he
said he wasn't sure whether he was
supposed to be allowed through or not
got his nose broken by a guard on the
way that he thought I better keep
running we don't know how long the walls
gonna be open to take a broader view
you're Henry Kissinger at the Council on
Foreign Relations a few days ago in
remembrance of this with leading
academics of the world including your
Germany what is the tone of Angela
Merkel
if she goes to Sunday she grew up in
that East Germany didn't she she grew up
in the night Angela Merkel well the wall
came down it was finally open on born
homeless draw so just about a kilometer
from her then apartment you know what
she did she went to the sauna after the
sauna what'd she do she had a beer she
didn't quite know that it was real and
it wasn't until the next day that she
had she fed class that she had her lab
her physics lab to tend to the next day
she crossed over went to the shopping
districts in the West Berlin saw the
opulence saw the excess so Merkel has a
very personal relation with this one
other thing on this is a Merkel and this
kind of gets back to the tech debate
that we talked about a lot and the NSA
eavesdropping Merkel lived in the former
East which means that the Stasi was a
real presence and personal privacy is
very much prized by her that drives her
today is she thinks and makes decisions
on tech and national security issues I
like the way you bring in the emotion of
Merkel who grew up in East Germany of
course this is that this will be the
25th anniversary you've got an entire
generation of kids who were not there
when the Berlin Wall came down what is
the emotion of the Millennials well
welcome when he was doing
the East don't really understand you
know the significance of it for the
generation that say in their 40s and 50s
those on the East may have been left
behind just a little bit I mean you look
at the number of board members from the
west and the east
it really doesn't compare I mean board
members that grew up in the East so
these would be men and women in their
50s 60s just a handful on Germany's top
companies even when you look at the big
companies throughout Europe throughout
Germany a handful are in the old East
most of those are utilities you do have
some big auto plants you got BMW and
Porsche and live stage which is in the
East well there's a huge economic
difference stone Hans Nichols thank you
so much from Berlin